I know you've had a pretty eventful last
few months so thank you for taking the
time you're here to talk about medium
but we're gonna talk about Twitter first
you said in your own medium post that
you've had more conference calls in the
last three months than you've had in
your entire life so there may be slight
exaggeration but turns out there's a lot
of conference calls involved in doing a
CEO search so how and why did you come
to the decision to bring Jack in as
permanent CEO well we thought long and
hard about it obviously and everyone
from beginning knew knew that jack was
capable and he had a unique perspective
on the company there's a question of
could he do both both this the Twitter
job in the square job and so we wanted
to see what our options are and that was
our job as a board to look far and wide
and eventually we thought the the
combination of what Jack brings to the
table and what he had already done in
the last three or four months convinced
us that he was the best person for the
job so how do you really feel about the
fact that he's doing two jobs I mean
Elon Musk was on stage yesterday saying
he doesn't recommend it yeah well I
don't think Jack would recommend it
either from talking to him but you know
he's got his commitments that Square and
and it's not ideal no one would say this
is ideal that that we want anyone's time
to split but it's it didn't change the
fact that we still thought despite that
it was the best choice and if your work
is not done you guys want to reformulate
the Twitter board and find a new
chairman what are you looking for in a
new Twitter board and particularly in a
chairman
I think that's we're just at the
beginnings of figuring that out really
so I can't speak to that too much we
were fully focused on the CEO searched
for a while and and it wasn't till
deciding for sure that Jack was the CEO
that we knew you know what we needed a
new board and he's obviously gonna play
a big role in that the chairman CEO need
to have a good relationship a lot of
attention has been paid in the past to
the EV jack relationship
how's it doing now it's really well I'd
say it's better than spent in years
we've come together through this process
I mean we i'm joked that twitter is like
our mutual child so you know we we've
come together and we we hold its future
as our highest priorities and we we see
eye to eye on most things when it comes
to future of twitter
how much do you see yourself working
with him on the product going forward
I'm I'm happy to be helpful where I can
I mean and you know I I'm fully focused
on medium I'm not perhaps as good as
splitting my time as as Jack is but I I
will help wherever I can so let's talk
about medium you've got a big event in
San Francisco tonight you're gonna
unveil something give us a clue we're
gonna bail a few things and you know
it's it's a bunch of things some of its
product we've wrapped up a bunch of new
features particularly in our apps we're
really seeing new new versions of our
apps that they're there's some
partnerships that we're announcing at
the same time and then a little bit
about our future plans about how how to
make make publishing sustainable on the
platform and on the internet so we're
really excited about just but it's it's
a it's a wide collection of stuff you
guys recently raised fifty seven million
capital we did what does that get you
what are you gonna do with the money um
it gets this time it gets this momentum
has been building on medium a lot this
year there's more publishing everyday
there's more reading every day and
really what that that that lets us do is
extend our runway for a good long while
while we build the business that's
really the focus Google announcing
accelerated mobile web pages today
they're working with Twitter on it you
know what's your take on this do you see
that
for medium to be part of this it's great
it's a user user focus user experience
focus feature I think everybody is
seeing the same thing that speed and
convenience always win in the end and
that has a lot to do with why we build
medium because we see if we can build a
seamless reading and writing experience
at all integrates very nicely then
people are gonna use that that's where
they're gonna go versus a thousand
different websites that load slowly
especially on the mobile phone and so
everybody sees that in its create a
different solution store the same goal
somebody recently called medium the PR
Newswire for a new generation so what
unflatteringly what was your reaction to
that well it's it's obviously a
short-sighted take on it mediums a
publishing platform gives everybody a
voice it gives individuals voice gives
companies and organizations all those
people are publishers on the web now
millions and millions of websites are
basically promotional websites they will
publish on platforms and and a lot and
publish on medium it's a small
percentage of overall medium publishing
but obviously it's there just like
Twitter is full of promotions YouTube is
full of promotions all major content
platforms have a marketing component
last quick question what does success
for Twitter and Jack look like in five
years 30 seconds I mean Twitter's just
getting started in terms of its
potential and and I think jack has it
can can unlock that and really the team
that is going to unlock it and it's
gonna be much bigger than it is now